بعد اقل من ساعتين انظار العالم تتجه
للرياض لمتابعه كاس موسم الرياض وترامب
يفاوض مثلا لاعاده حساباته و25 سؤال مع
النجمه امل عرفه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
انذار العالم كله محبي كره القدم تحديدا
متجهات الى الرياض الي بتنطلق فيها
المواجهه المنتظر بين النجوم الهلال
والنصر ضد باريس سان جيرمان على كاس موسم
الرياضي طبعا المباراه هذه المباراه
الهلال والنصر مجتمعين في فريق واحد هذه
مواجهه بين افضل لاعبين في العالم ميسي
ورونالدو ومباراه بتجمع اهم نجوم اللعبه
في العالم وكان اعلن رئيس هيئه الترفيه
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ عن وصول طلبات
التذاكر لمليونين طلب بعضها هذه غير تذكره
فوق الخيال بمميزات خياليه واللي عمل
عليها مزاد وصل لعشره مليون ريال وهيروح
رايح لصالح منصه احسان الخيريه الاجواء
حماسيه مشدوده صراحه النجوم الرياضيين
اليوم مجتمعين في الرياض على استاد الملك
فهد الدولي هذا غير انها اول مباراه كمان
لرونالدو في السعوديه
ومن ساعات الصباح بدا بث خاص بكاس موسم
الرياض على شاهد وعلي تابع الجميع كمان
وصول فريق باريس سان جيرمان الى الرياض
اللي كان في استقبالهم المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ
[موسيقى]
وكان معالي المستشار التقى امس نجوم
الهلال والنصر او فريق موسم الرياض ووجه
لهم كلمات
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله انا اتمنى ان بكره تاخذوا
المباراه بجديه والكاس يبقى في الرياض يلا
شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
تركي ال الشيخ عن رقم قياسي مليوني جديد
حققوا الموسم بوصول عدد دائري الى 12
مليون زائر والفعاليات مكمله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مفاوضات جاريه بين فريق ترامب ومتى سمعنا
عنها اليوم لاول مره الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب ومثل ما كلنا يعني
عارفين غايب عن كبرى من الصوت السوشال
ميديا من 20 21 وقت احداث الكابتل اللي
نحضر من بعدها من معظم من الصوت وعلى
رقصات تويتر وفيسبوك والانستغرام ويوتيوب
وغيرها وقتها كان يعني هو النجوم من
الصوتي يعني على تويتر كان من اصحاب
الحسابات الاكثر نشاطا وشعبيه ب 87 مليون
متابع ام على فيسبوك عنده كان 34 مليون
متابع وعلى الانستغرام 23 مليون والحسابين
هذولي لسه موجودين على فكره واخر بوست
عليهم من يناير 20 واحد و20 ولكن من وقتها
ما بيقدر ينشر عليهم شيء وترامب بعد الحذر
راح اطلق منصه الخاصه
بارع المفاوضات بنت ترامب ومتى فمحامي
ترامب بعد رساله للشركات بالنيابه عنه
بيطالب فيها باعاده فوريه لحسابات الرئيس
السابق على فيسبوك وانستغرام وقالت
الرساله انه الحظر المفروض على ترامب تشوه
الخطاب
العامته وقالوا لهم يلا فورا اجتماع نناقش
فيه عوده ترمب الفوريه
والحظر المستمر راح نعتبره جهد متعمد
لاسكات صوت ترامب السياسي ترامب طبعا
للعوده بما انه ناوي الترشح للرئاسه للمره
الثالثه وحسابات منصات التواصل صارت عنصر
اساسي من اي حمل يعني هو طبعا سيد
العارفين في هذا الموضوع كثار على فكره
شافه الخبر واستغربوا انه يعني يرجع
فيسبوك وانستغرام مع انه لما الماسك رجع
له حسابه على تويتر ما غرد هناك ولا قال
اي شيء لكن كثيرا على هذا الكلام ففي
مصادر مقربه بتقول انه بيدرس قال
تجعه وتكلم اكثر من مره في الموضوع وانه
حتى مستشاري عملوا له كذا مسوده لتغريدته
الاولى بعد الرجعه ماسك بالمناسبه ما فوت
خبر ترامب مع متى واللي يعني النقاش اللي
صاير بينهم وعلق على تغريده مقال عن تجهيز
ترامب نفسه للرجعه للفيسبوك وتويتر وقال
انه سيكون من الممتع نتفرج كيف رح تتعامل
اداره مع هذا الخبر يمكن يجرب ويسلحه
وكالات فيدراليه ضد توت تويتر
اهلا من جديد موعدنا الان مشاهدينا مع
فقره 25 سؤال وظيفتنا لهذا الاسبوع النجمه
امل عرفه اترككم مع الفقره واعود والقاكم
الاحد ان شاء الله في امان الله
امل عرفه 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم
كل نفس الشيء دي كل نفس الشيء بعيده لان
اي شيء عملته انا
بزمن سابق او بعمر معين فهو نتيجه الوعي
بهذا الكلام اوكي اغنيه بتعبر عن حياتك
يا مرايتي
لا صعب كثير لانه انا عندي بدايه
البطوله امامك من ناحيه الكيمياء بينكم
كثار
فعلا
الخبز والملح
بيبدوا اجل الانترفيو بهداك الوقت زمن هيك
شويه نشاز جاوبت بتسرع هذا اللي قالت لي
اياه يعني بس انا برد انه ديما ديما شقفه
من قلبي يعني اوكي طيب ايش استفدتي من
التجربه التقديم البرامج استفدت كثير لانه
تعجبتيني تقديم البرامج لم تقتصر فقط على
برنامج في امل من سنتين بالتسعينات قدمت
برامج على الام بي سي وقدمت على ار تي
وقدمت على كثير محطات برامج اطفال
نافذه ثانيه لك يعني انا بالاساس ممثله بس
لما بلاقي برنامج حلو مهم كمان بيحبني لما
بلاقي اغنيه حلوه
ولما بلاقي فكره كويسه بتحبني اكتبها
وسببها
اكيد اكيد ممثله اوكي عمل قدمتيه الاسباب
ماديه
كتار خاصه بفتره كنت
ضائقه ماديه صعب قولوا لانه بيجرح الناس
الي يشتغلوا فيه اوكي
حابه تصدقيها طبعا انا بعيش من شغلي فقط
لا غير طيب مثلا تعطيني سنين السنين
ههه
يعني بدك تقولي بين اي شيء قبل ال 2017
انا عندي غير بعد 2017 بالسنه اللي فات
فيها والدي والسنه اللي صار عندي همم هذا
همم
اوكي تمام
ولا عمل سوري سوري
مو بس مسلسل يا اللي قمت بالشراكه
بالانتاج والانقاذ مشروعي فقط لا غير يعني
دخلت ليس رغبه مني يعني همم
شو كان السؤال انه ايش السبب اللي فشل هذه
التجربه من وجهه نظرك ما فشلت التجربه
العمل ما نعرضت كفايه ما اخذ وقته كثير
همم اعتقد انه اذا فشل ولا اذا نجاح
كلياتنا بنتحمل المسؤوليه بس وهي بجوز
يكون سوء اختيار بجوز يكون همم تسرع
بمنطقه معينه او من ناحيه معينه
اذا كان
اوكي يعني المشكله طيب ليش بتعبر يعني
عرفتك التملي فكره الزواج مره اخرى والله
ما بعرف
ما بعرف يعني الدرجه مره سالتي قلتي فعل
الله ولا فالك ليه
بحس انه
انا حدا قدري كثير وحقيقه انا مسلمه امري
لله
ماني مدوره على شخص احبه ولا مرتبط فيه
ولا اتجوز ولا عيد مره ثانيه بقدر انا
عايشه حاله سلام عندي ستايل لحياتي عايشته
ومبسوطه فيك كثر خير الله مع بناتي همم
اي شخص بده يدخل على حياتي يضيف سلام لهذا
السلام اوكي
بابا اسماعيل اي كلمات مديح باذنك يطلعيها
من اذنك هاي لانه ما بدهم لحدا انت شو بدك
من هذه المهنه اصلا انك همم فن ولا رساله
ولا احترام من الناس ولا محبه ولا ولا
تحديد الاولويات الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
يعني
بس لا اكثر خير الله الحمد لله الحمد لله
ايش احلى شيء في عمر الخمسين
انك بتعرفي حالك تمام اااه بتحسي انه
بتعرفي كيف تسعدي نفسك
بتعرفي شو بدك من الحياه وشو الحياه
بتعرفي تماما كيف دائره الناس اللي انت
بتعرفيهم خلص انت مكتفيه ما يعني يلي بده
يدخل جديد بده يكون كثير
مش كثير يستاهل اوكي ما عاد في بيصير عندك
قناعه انه انا قداحه عايش لسه اذا انا
بالخمسين
عشر سنين ثاني
ليش ما بنشوفك في اعمال الدراما المشتركه
السوريه واللبنانيه لان ما صار طلب جريده
العاده انه هذول الاعمال فقط ينعملوا على
مبدا نجم سوري
انا عملت مع جورج خباز
اسمه براند الشرق وانا اصلا بدبي هون بس
انت بتحسي بشكل عام انه يعني دائما لازم
هي الممثله تكون لبنانيه وهو سوري ولوجات
نجمه سوريه ثانيه فلازم تكون سنيده في
العمل ما بحس وهذه الحقيقه اممم هذه
الحقيقه تقريبا طيب دور صانع اسمك
سمر بالي خمس نجوم الجوارح همم العنقاء
بالجواهر طلعوا بنفس السنه هادول
وبعده نستمرت الاعمال كمان في خان الحرير
بالجزء الاول والثاني في الضفه الغجريه مع
هيثم حقي همم الجوارح مع نشدات الزهور مع
هشام شربجي
يعني بتعبر عن ارائك السياسيه بصراحه هل
خسرك هذا الشيء انا ما عبرت انا رئيس
السياسه على فكره
السياسيه
واللي بيهمني من كل شيء بالدنيا انه بلدي
تبقى بخير والسرور يبقى بخير
عن رايك في الازمه السوريه
يعني همم
قرروا اشياء ثانيه العلاقه بي بي كواليس
بغضب معينه من الناس في وقت حساس
يمكن الناس بتحسب انه فلان مع هون وفلان
مع هون انا
مع البلد نفسها مع اي شيء بصير لمصلحه
البلد
وشايفه قديش الناس همم لسه ما امنه انه
هذا البلد هيوقف على حاله اوكي
بالاضاءه بالصوت
[موسيقى]
كان عندي لما يكون ضيف عندي شويه همم
ايقاع وهيك على الهدف فكنت حمسه
شد ايقاع كثير لدرجه انه ببعض المرات قطعت
وهذا منيح همم ما عم بقول لك انه كان لازم
ينعمل مثلا خمس ست حلقات هذا اللي طلبته
انا وبعدين نوقف ونشوف شو العيوب وبعدين
نكمله نصلح نكمل بعد التصليح وساده ما صار
هل الرجال دمهم اخف من النساء وعشان كده
عدد الكوميديانت من الرجال اكثر كلها ابدا
ههه
لا بس هي جابت العادي انه صعب يكون فيكم
يعني همم ممثله وبنسرق تكون جميله رغم انه
في كثير في كثير ممثلات كسروا هذه القاعده
كان بمصر ولا بالخليج ولا سوري سوريا
طيب لو تختصر انفصالك عن النجم عبد المنعم
عمايري في كلمه ايش بتكون
قدر الله وما شاء فعل
جدا جدا جدا وهي نجمه كمان سوريا
اخبار من 2014 انا لحد الان انا ما بفتح
نشره اخبار العلميه ابدا يعني بسمع هيك
همم عناوين قصص بس اني انا اشوف مشاهد عنف
او مشاهد هاي انا ما ما الحقيقه ما قدرت
اتحمل وعملت لي اذى نفسي شديد شاني شان
كثار من السوريين لكن انا هلا بعتبر انه
انه انا بنت همم بنت الشعب السوري بصرف
النظر هذا السوري شو موقفه السياسي
طلعوني وقفوني على رجليه وحبوني ودعموني
وانا عندي استعداد اعمل الكل انه
الانسانيه همم
لكن الانسانيه لا تتجزا واعتذاري انا
مسؤوله عنه وبعده لهلا موجود على صفحتي
بالتواصل الاجتماعي رغم انه كلفني كثير
لانه ولا احد رضي يكتب شيء لا من الجهال
وانت جيبي وقتها ولا من الكاتب ولا من
الممثلين
وحسيت انه ممنوع ما ما
بتقول هدول الكلمتين دول تتمنى اداءه او
كتابته دور اتمنى ايه همم هلا عم بشتغل
على شيء بس صعب احكي عن الموضوع
شخصيه
طيب بناتك سلمى ومريم ايش اخذوا منك وايش
اخذوا من والدهم الفنان عبد المنعم عمايري
سلمى الكبيره اخده من ابوها ااه
ما بعرف اذا المفرده صح ولا لا الا
الشيطان هيك يعني
اي موقف حرج حلو يبقى انا كثير عارفاني شو
اللي عم يصير يعني فهي بتقدر تهريب حاله
وبعدين بتيجي بتحكي لي اوكي اوكي
[موسيقى]
لا نسبه لعمره همم
بحس انه عندها حكمه اكبر من عمره
فاعتقد انه اخذ مني همم وعبد طبعا حكيم
لكن هو شوي انفعالي اكثر مني
بس الحضور اخذينه من عبد المنعم يعني مش
مني لا مني ومنه اوكي مني ومنه طيب لو عرض
عليك المشاركه في مسلسل
انعرض يعني
انا كمان عم بصور
كثير
بس الحقيقه
يكون المسلسل مع مين كان ما ما فت بتفاصيل
اوكي لو طلبت منك تختاري مشهد واحد من
تاريخك تعتبريه الاصعب اي مشهد تختاري
همم كثار المشاهد الصعبه اللي عملتها
بحياتي اللي هي هيك ماستر يعني بتعتبر
[موسيقى]
اصعب مشهد كان بيموتني همم ثلاثيه مواطن
اللي بتحكي عن اللجوء عبر البحر
كنا نحنا وانا مو عن حالي بس عم بحكي هلا
كنا نحنا الممثلين نصور البحر
اااه لسعات طويله
فكنا نقول انه اذا نحن تصويره هيك كيف اذا
حقيقه يعني
طيب اختاري اغنيه واهديها لشخص معين
باختار
[موسيقى]
وحياه قلبي وافراحه لعبد الحليم
سلمى
بس انا واثقه انه هي راح تعمل شيء هيك
قلبها من جوا يفرح ان شاء الله يخليه لكم
يا رب
وتفرحي فيهم ان شاء الله شكرا يا امل
[موسيقى]